[Music]
foreign
hearing for the government just a few
moments ago I spoke to the chancellor of
the duchy of Lancaster the cabinet
offers Minister Oliver Dalton
the Home Secretary visited Rwanda she
said migrants could be deported there
within months
um at the same time though this policy
has been in action since April no one
has actually left to Rwanda yet you'll
forgive me for my skepticism
well the first thing I should say is and
I think I've been in your show before
when you've talked about these huge
numbers of migrants we're determined to
grip this problem and stop the boats now
Rwanda forms one part of that the reason
why we haven't been able to proceed with
Rwanda is because it's currently before
the courts we actually succeeded at the
high court stages before the court of
appeal but as soon as that process is
through and I'm confident our policy is
lawful we will get cracking straight
away with the Rwanda policy and use that
as a tool in our army essentially what
we're saying and this comes through in
the legislation as well that we
announced earlier this month you cannot
come to this country by crossing the
channel and if you do so you'll either
be repatriated to your home country or
you'll be center around us so it's part
of that mix but it sits alongside other
things we've done so for example the
Albania deal where we're seeing many
flights going back to Albania already or
the work that's been done with the
French all of this is demonstration of
of the government gripping this problem
and stopping the boats anyone who comes
to the country on a small boat that
includes children who come with their
families you personally comfortable with
that idea that I don't relish any of
this and I really wish we didn't have to
do it and the government isn't running
to do this the government is doing this
because this is a major
problems
we are being forced to do it and I'll
tell you why we're being forced to it I
think with those children seeking to
cross the channel I think of the danger
that their lives are being put in the
evil people Smugglers and whose hands
their place and unless we are willing as
a government and as a country to take
tough action in relation to this the
numbers will keep on growing and more
people's lives will be put at risk
including the lives of young children
and I'm simply not willing to allow that
to happen if this is such great policy
then why do the Home Secretary only
invite right-leading media organizations
to Rwanda with her GB news the Sun the
express the mail on that play not Sky
News not the BBC not the eye or the
guardian why are you scared of scrutiny
forgive me I don't know the details of
who the Home Secretary
and I've heard the visit the the details
that you've given me the logistics of a
trip are a matter for the home so it's
probably not in for the Home Secretary
for her her operations team I'm sure
there'll be plenty of opportunities uh
for the BBC and for Sky to scrutinize
the Home Secretary about it and indeed
you have me uh in front of you this
morning to talk to you and I'm delighted
to be on sky as I always am I do and I'm
glad you're delighted to run the program
but we've never had the chance to screw
I have never had a chance to scrutinize
a Home Secretary on this it's going
alongside others not invited on that
trip it does look like you're running
away from scrutiny
well as I said you Sophie I simply uh
don't know the details of individual
operational decisions but I'm very happy
for our policy to be scrutinized because
I'm confident that under Rishi sunak as
our prime minister we are gripping this
problem we're taking difficult decisions
as you rightly highlighted but we're
determined to stop this evil traffic
continuing Zoella Brotherman on this
visit visited some of the potential
long-term homes for migrants in Rwanda
and she said I really like your interior
designer I need some advice for myself
I mean
is that a bit tone deaf we're talking
here about families children like making
a dangerous journey and being sent to
Rwanda to live long term
in temp in this town well I I think that
what you can actually see you can see it
for uh this picture I think she's with
Nim girlie there but the um
this is about people having a safe and
secure place to go so contrary to some
of this characteristics
contrary to some of this
characterization of the policy this is
about making sure there is somewhere
safe and secure for people to go to and
actually the purpose of the home
secretaries visit was to further
strengthen our relationships with Rwanda
so people should feel confident in this
policy that ideally people would come to
this country on Route and they'd get
they'd claim asylum in the first safe
country they come to they could do so in
France Belgium and so on if they cross
the the channel they can't remain here
they'll either go back to their home
country or they go to around you and you
can see from that that isn't this is a
perfectly safe and secure place to go to
is it safe for everyone in Rwanda the
home office did an equality impact of
assessment for the policy uh last year
they found that there are concerns over
the treatment of gay and lesbian people
there and that the ill treatment is more
than a one-off is it safe for everyone
yes I am confident that it is is safe
for people and actually the United
Nations for example has used a Rwanda as
a refugee destination and through our
engagement with the Rwandan authorities
and government we are confident that
people will be safe there this is
concerns by the your own equality impact
assessment well I'm of course quality
impact assessments are produced for
every policy and then it's up to
ministers to consider that now I'm
confident the Home Secretary will have
considered that and I'm confident that
because of the discussions we've had
with around us because of the fact the
United Nations uses Rwanda that this is
a safe place for people to go to but in
all of this these are not easy decisions
these are difficult decisions but
they're being done for a purpose which
is to stop the boats and we have to do
this to restore control to our migration
system
um Sola bravman in a recent article in
the Daily Mail wrote unless we act today
the problem will be even worse tomorrow
there are 100 million people just laced
around the world unlikely billions more
eager to come here if possible
billions more
is that right well it is a a function of
the global economy and differences in
levels of development that countries
like the United Kingdom France Germany
United States and others have
potentially vast numbers of people who
wish to come here as economic migrants
secondly if you let me finish this point
secondly it is the case that you look at
the numbers we we were at a situation
where there were dozens of boats three
or four years ago we're at forty
thousand uh last year projected to rise
further we have to be willing to put a
stop to this and there are very very
large numbers of people who could
potentially wish to enter the United
Kingdom and indeed other developed
countries for for economic migration
reasons 40 000 you say
you're taking two things slightly out of
context so what she's making the she's
making the point which is
perfectly correct which is that these
numbers are increasing very very rapidly
and if we don't take action the the
numbers could increase and increase and
increase again and the potential pool of
people which I think is what she's
referring to with the the billions is
the fact that if you look at a global
population of I think of about 8 billion
people many billions of those people are
not in economically developed countries
like our own so could potentially wish
to migrate for economic reasons and I
think that that's the the argument she's
making I mean Gary lineker likened this
kind of language to that used in 1930s
Germany but I think that's deeply
offensive and there's somebody who
represents a community with a very large
number of of Jewish uh people in it the
these the comparison between policies by
this government to legitimately stop
dangerous illegal migration and the
evils of the Nazi regime I find it
hauling that people could draw parallels
between the two of them and deeply
offensive right we need to move on to
other issues and now you're announcing
an emergency alert system that will come
to people's mobile devices just explain
what the idea is here so the idea of
this is that in a situation where there
is a serious risk to life people will
receive an alert on their phone it's
basically just broadcast from mobile
phone masks and can be reduced to an
award level and you only receive that in
the most serious of circumstances and it
will warn you about action that you need
to take this is one tool in the toolkit
that the government has to deal with the
most serious situations and it could be
that that alert could save your life now
I don't expect this to be used very
often in fact I hope it isn't used at
all but as part of our preparedness for
it we will be having a trial in about
months time on the 23rd of April so
everyone will hear their phone Buzz it's
quite a loud siren for about 10 seconds
there's no need for anyone to to do
anything but that's just a test to make
sure that it can reach everyone's phone
and this capability can reach up to 90
of people so it's an important tool to
help us deal with resilience what kind
of scenarios do you expect it to be used
in well I think it will only be used in
very serious situations where there is a
significant risk to life so I would
think for most people they wouldn't
expect to hear this Buzz possibly not
ever or certainly not for a few years it
broadly replicates what happens in other
countries so for example the United
States Japan the Netherlands and and
what really it would be it would be for
things like natural disasters
potentially terrorist incidents is that
correct yes but it would depend on the
individual circumstances so take an
example for example if there's a very
severe flooding situation where your
home is at risk of being inundated and
your life could be in danger if you're
remain in your home in that area you
will receive an alert in respect of
Terror incidents it will depend on the
operational advice that we receive from
the counterterra police and the others
because clearly it will depend on the
circumstance says it may well not be
appropriate to have a loud Alert in in
some situations uh in in others it could
be the case that a warning is required
for people
now lots of our viewers this morning the
one thing they're going to want to know
more than any other thing is what is
going on with public sector strikes now
the governments and talk to the teaching
unions and also Junior doctors I believe
can you tell us what's going on well
first of all uh in respect to What's
called the agenda for for change so that
covers nurses ambulance workers and so
on we make good progress we've we've
reached what I believe is a fair deal
and that will go to their memberships
and I hope their memberships will will
accept that in respect of the teachers
those discussions are ongoing with the
education secretary in respect of the
junior doctors our door remains open for
those discussions and we've had some
initial contact with them but but formal
negotiations are are not ongoing but I
would very much hope that those can
happen and that we can get to a
situation where we have a a decent a pay
deal for public sector workers but one
that respects our public finances and
respects the pressure on inflation I
think that that's what we've got to with
the agenda for change Workforce and I
hope it's where we could get to
elsewhere are you optimistic with the
teaching talks because obviously lots of
parents have seen a lot of disruption
with schools closing yes no indeed I
I've seen that disruption myself and I
very much hope that we can get to a
situation where it's resolved we will
just have to wait and see how those
negotiations go I really don't want to
understand one way or the other you do
talk about the agenda for change group
rather
um there has been a breakthrough
obviously that's going to go to the
membership with the five percent payers
for nurses plus a one-off payment this
year there is a bit of concern about how
this is going to be funded though um if
you look at the submission of evidence
from the Department for health this was
to the independent pay of your body this
year they said funding is available for
pay Awards up to 3.5 percent pay Awards
Above This level would require
trade-offs for Public Service delivery
or further government borrowing
obviously the pay award we're talking
about here is five percent so are these
tridos going to happen in elsewhere in
the NHS budget uh well as you say first
of all there's the three and a half
percent uh already there so it's the
remaining amount this is fairly standard
practice for for reaching additional
public uh expenditure requirements the
NHS has a budget of uh 100 will go up to
160 billion pounds we're clear that we
won't uh affect Frontline Services by
doing this so there won't be any cuts to
NHS Services it will have to be
delivered through efficiency or from
wider savings across government it is
perfectly normal to work through that
process but indeed it does illustrate
the challenges all this finally this
money is not easy but we think that in
this context of ensuring that uh we
reward nurses properly and we prevent
disruption that we can find the money to
do this but it won't be easy I mean so
it's existing budgets effectively the
health secretary on Thursday said it
won't come from areas of the budget that
impact on patients
I'll be honest I really find this very
hard to get my head around can you
explain what areas of the NHS budget
doesn't impact patients well I would say
two things so first of all it doesn't
necessarily have to come uh within the
uh the envelope for the the NHS of the
160 billion pounds is the wider
Department of Health budget and there's
The Wider budget across all of
government and it's usual to work
through with the treasury to find where
those relationships
so if you just let me finish on this
um on on this point but even within the
160 billion for the NHS not all of that
is going to be for Frontline uh services
so the Frontline Services we think about
are of course your hospitals your
doctor's surgeries and so on within a
budget that large the it is there is
potential to get efficiencies
because it does feel right my point is
that anywhere in the department for
health if you're talking about for
example social care that does have an
impact on patient care as well we know
know the link between social care and
the NHS we talk about efficiency savings
well anyone who tries to get an
appointment and realizes the lengthy
process it takes to takes admin in the
NHS also impacts patients it feels quite
disingenuous to me to say that it won't
impact patient care well given the
pressure that health services around the
world are under we're not going to take
Services away from the the front line I
don't deny for minutes over your point
which is that it is challenging to find
this money this is why the government
held out for so long in respect of these
negotiations because there wasn't some
huge amount of money that we could turn
to but that I am confident that we we
can find it either within the NHS
budgets or wider government uh spending
okay now next week on Wednesday we're
going to have a vote on the brexit deal
the so-called Windsor framework
are you optimistic with DP you're going
to come on board
well look that's that's a matter for the
uh for the the dup I hope that they uh
will come on board but I really don't
want to preempt decisions that they're
going to make but I think what you you
have seen and indeed you've seen this
with the Windsor agreement many other
things that has come done has done we
are getting a grip of challenges facing
this country many people said it
wouldn't be possible to achieve the kind
of treaty changes we've achieved to
ensure that there is effectively no
border for goods East-West between
Mainland Great Britain and the rest of
UK United Kingdom nor nine that in turn
those actions by the Prime Minister have
commanded widespread support across
different political parties and across
the conservative party so I'm confident
that the vote will succeed and pass and
I hope we will do so with the support of
the DU P But ultimately that is for them
uh now next week let's be honest on
Wednesday it may all be completely
overshadowed by the Boris Johnson show
because he is going to be in front of
the Privileges committee investigating
whether or not he misled Parliament over
party gay now according to the Sunday
Telegraph his team are preparing to
unveil bombshell evidence to exonerate
him that will show in their words he was
advised to say what went on what he went
on and said
oh it sounds a little bit like he's
preparing to throw his AIDS onto the bus
well I'm I'm sure that first of all I
should say this is a matter for the the
house authorities and for the relevant
uh committee and
um it's not really for ministers to give
running commentaries on these things but
I'm sure uh Boris Johnson will give a
robust defense of himself and then it
will be for the committee to to
determine the outcome of it it's not
helpful is it though
well this this is a process that was
initiated by the House of Commons and of
course the house comms is entirely at
Liberty to to make whatever decisions it
it wants to I'm sure the uh former prime
minister Boris Johnson will provide a
robust defense and it will be then up to
the the committee to make their
determination
um according to reports is going to
offer conservative MPS of free votes uh
if the Privileges committee finds
against Boris Johnson would that be the
right thing to do well the standard
practice in on what we call house
matters so matters that are being led by
their the the House of Commons that
relate to these sort of things it is
standard practice not to whip the vote
um I don't I'm not sure final decisions
have been made but that would be the
precedent that you would expect to
follow that's not going to really help
her allies of Boris Johnson right
well it's a fairly well established
principle that we don't interfere in
in-house business but as I said I'm sure
that roster Johnson's will provide a a
robust defense and it will be for the
the committee to make its determination
and then just finally you're obviously
closer if she's unac I think you'd
probably describe yourself as a friend
how would you describe his feelings
towards Boris Johnson
I think actually he has a a lot of
respect for Boris Johnson indeed I think
any prime minister and I've seen this
with I've had the privilege of knowing a
number of prime ministers when they
become Prime Minister they realize quite
how demanding the job of being prime
minister is and have respect for all of
their predecessors and and he has that
respect for Boris Johnson as well okay
thank you very much indeed
thanks Effie
that was Oliver Darden speaking to us a
little earlier well let's get Labor's
view now we can speak to the party
Shadow leveling up secretary Lisa nandy
he was in Salford good to speak to you
today at least nandy we just heard from
Oliver Dowden talking about the
government's policy on Rwanda he said he
doesn't relish any of it but the
government is being forced to do it
because of the increasing number of
small boats crossing the channel is that
fair enough
well forced to do what everyone accepts
that this is a major problem it's a
crisis we've got record number of boats
arriving on the coast criminal gangs
profiting and an asylum system in chaos
but the question is what is the
government actually doing so far they've
done several PR opportunities and photo
ops we've had 140 million pounds of
checks written to Rwanda in order to
implement a scheme that hasn't removed a
single person this is just more stunts
from this government what they should be
doing is what Labor's been calling for
for a very long time take the money that
is being spent on this unethical
unworkable scheme and puts it into the
National Crime agency to create a
cross-border cell in order to disrupt
the criminal gangs who are profiting
from people's misery that will be the
best way to stop the small boats and
back it up with proper resources at the
front end of the Asylum system so that
we can process cases swiftly and get a
great on what has become an unwieldy
system that is completely out of control
you know what that would be the best
thing to do if we're living in a perfect
world but the fact is we're really not
if it was that easy to stop the
smuggling gowns you'd see other
countries in the world doing it you know
Interpol themselves or saying how
difficult it is they're not like usual
unorganized crime because of the
transient nature of their relationships
with their victims you know burn of
phones they often don't know their real
names you know labor could say that it
wants to wave a magic wand and just
smash the smuggling gangs but that's not
a serious solution
I don't think that diverting resources
into setting up a specialist National
Crime agency cell is waving a magic wand
what it's doing is the hard yards that
this government hasn't been prepared to
do to tackle what is a very challenging
criminal problem that is exploiting some
of the most desperate people in the
world people who will are fleeing War
who are fleeing persecution are
relieving such desperate circumstances
that unless we do roll up our sleeves
and do the hard yards to deal with the
problem at source the conditions that
they're fleeing to deal with an asylum
system that leaves people languishing
for months and often years waiting for a
decision to deal with criminal gangs who
have ruthlessly exploited the fact that
this government has refused to get a
grip on the problem has refused to work
constructively with other countries in
order to do so unless we do that we're
going to see what we've seen for the
last decade which is this problem
continue to get worse and worse the bill
is going up the waiting times are going
up the number of boats are going up
since the Prime Minister said he was
going to get a grip on this and
legislate to stop it last year we've
seen the number of Boat Crossings reach
record highs 45
000 last year the government continues
to make promises big talk and photo
opportunities but what we're calling for
is precisely the action that you talked
about Sophie not a magic wand not a
silver bullet but real work to to tackle
these gangs to tackle this problem and
to make sure that where we do offer
people Sanctuary we can do so swiftly
and humanely and restore Britain's
reputation in the world again
um I also put some of sweller
brotherman's language to Oliver downden
saying that it's the kind of language
that Gary lineker likened to that used
in 1930s Germany he said that that was
an appalling comparison by the match of
the day presenter is it
well look I think what people say Gary
lineker said is very different from what
Gary lineker actually said the
government has been Keen to say that he
was likening this to the Nazis that he
wasn't and I would have utterly
condemned that had he done so I don't
think he would have done so frankly what
he was pointing to was a chilling
comparison uh with an environment in
which people aren't free to be able to
challenge this sort of language and
behavior don't forget it was Sue Ella
bravaman who used really inhumane
language about the migrant crisis which
was roundly condemned not just by people
outside of politics but by people across
the political Spectrum including some of
her own colleagues all of this comes
back to the same problem that the
government's policies their answers and
solutions their language is getting
increasingly more outlandish because
they're not prepared to do the work to
actually disrupt the criminal gangs to
speed up the Asylum process and to work
with other countries to deal with the
problems that refugees are fleeing which
is creating instability around the world
now Rishi sunak came to office saying
that he was going to start focusing down
on cleaning up some of his own mess this
is one area where we need far less
posturing far less dangerous talk and
far more real action to deal with what
has been a real problem and labor has
been saying so for a very long time
I want to talk to you about brexit
because of course there will be the vote
next week on The Windsor framework
Oliver Darden says he's confident that
will pass not least of course because
labor is expected to back it do you
think it's a good deal for Northern
Ireland
look I think it's it's a step forward
and we will support a step forward as I
said a moment ago Rishi sunak is
prepared to go and start cleaning up
some of his own mess we're certainly not
going to criticize him for that and
there's no question that this is
something that is now urgent it's
incredibly important and trying to
remove some of that friction some of
those barriers on the island of Ireland
has long been our priority we think the
government ought to get on with it we
hope that vote passes and we hope that
Britain can now start to look to the
Future after 13 long years of drift and
decay under this Tory government this
was budget we this should have been the
moment where Britain got onto the front
foot and started leading the world not
leaving it started winning the race for
good jobs to get money back into
people's pockets started prioritizing
most people in most parts of the country
not just a handful of the wealthiest in
a few parts of the country and instead
here we still are talking about the Tory
failures of the past and how we're going
to fix them we just think Britain could
do so much better than this
talking about how you think Britain
should do better
um you of course are the shadow leveling
of secretary you want to see more
devolution
now that sounds great of course giving
more power to local communities across
the country but I just wonder in
practice
you know if you look at what is
happening in local authorities in
councils croydon's gone bust woking
Slough thoric Warrington just a few in
financial difficulties you know anyone
who's had any dealings with their actual
local Council might be thinking hang on
you want them to do more
well actually the pandemic paints a very
different story when the national system
just couldn't respond the government
reluctantly handed over the right to run
test trace and isolate systems and other
wrote the role out of the vaccine to
local authorities to Public Health
directors and to communities and we
responded we stepped forward and ran
effective systems in every part of the
country including greater Manchester
where I'm sitting now when the national
system just simply couldn't do it
because we know our own communities we
know the assets and the potential that
exists in those communities not just the
problems that Whitehall is Keen to focus
on and we were able to mobilize people
in order to get the vaccine rolled out
in record time and to get test trace and
isolate up and running 13 years of Tory
government has meant that councils are
reeling they've had 15 billion cut from
their budgets over that time and in this
budget buried in the detail of this
budget was a six billion pound council
tax bombshell or something actually the
government is forcing councils to put up
council tax in order to fund the
services that currently exist because
the national government has stepped out
of the picture but we believe that this
country could do far far better if we
actually trusted our local businesses
and our local communities to take charge
of their own destiny the government says
that they're in favor of doing that but
in this week's budget which should have
been a game changer they introduced
Evolution deals that cover just nine
percent of the population what about the
missing 90 percent of us we deserve far
better than to be treated by this
government as second-class Citizens on a
second class track to be able to
unshackle ourselves from 13 years of
Tory failure and start to grow our
economies and get money back into
people's pockets again
thank you very much indeed Lisa nandy
there speaking to us himself thank you
well you're watching Sophie Ridge on
Sunday we did a lot on the immigration
debate so far strong views on either
side of the argument plus still to come
on the program this morning
in just a moment we'll be talking to the
German ambassador to the UK Miguel Virgo
and a little later on we're going to be
hearing from the third of our s p
leadership candidate interviews this
time it will be Kate Forbes
plus we are going to get some immediate
reaction from our adaptive political
editor Sam Coates who's been watching
all of the interviews intently for us
this morning we'll speak to Sam a little
bit later on
[Music]
right let's crack on shall we with our
next interview because relationships
between the EU and the UK are certainly
a lot warmer shall we say with Rishi
CNAC in charge so I'm very pleased to
say that our next guest uh joins us now
on the program that is the ambassador
German ambassador to the UK Miguel
Berger thank you so much for being with
us on the program
um lots to talk to you about brexit
Ukraine but first if I may I want to
talk to you about immigration to start
and because the UK government is really
focusing on trying to stop desperate
people making the channel Crossings but
of course this isn't an issue just for
the UK Asylum Seekers are an issue for
many European countries as well
promised to stop the boats is that even
possible
very difficult to say it if it will be
possible but I agree that it's a wider
problem it's not only what is happening
in the channel
I think we have to look at migration
routes from Libya from Turkey from
Tunisia from many other countries we
have climate change which is producing
more refugees
so in the end I think what we will need
is a stronger international cooperation
to cope with this problem I just want to
have a look at some figures if I may
because I think if we look at the
graphic that I'm about to show you
Germany is clearly more Asylum Seekers
than the UK you can see the UK they're
in red this is the number of Asylum
applications for a hundred thousand
people uh Germany all the way up there
with 178 UK down at 87. how much of an
issue is in Germany it is an issue
because we have more than one million
refugees who came from Ukraine so that
is already a heavy burden plus all the
others from Syria Iraq Afghanistan so we
are also in a debate about what to do
and how to distribute the burden but the
difference is that in Germany Asylum and
to claim Asylum is a constitutional
right and so everybody who comes legally
or illegally can claim Asylum and will
be listened to that's interesting
because obviously UK there's a very
clear distinction between people who
come through the legal routes for the
schemes with Ukraine for example and
people who enter on small boats many
people think the only way to actually
stop the boats is to assign a returns
agreement so that they can be sent back
to France but obviously that would mean
not signing a returns agreement with
France but with the EU do you think
that's something that the EU would
consider I'm not sure that you will
consider that but the better way I think
is to talk to countries of origin like
Albania because in Germany we also I
think only accept less than one percent
of albanians as real Asylum Seekers the
majority comes for economic reasons so
we have an agreement to return them to
their country of origin and I think this
is the way to go but let me really
clearly say Sophie that for us I think
the important thing is to respect
international law and that means the the
Geneva Refugee convention and the
European convention for human rights do
you think that the UK is respecting
international law then I've seen that
the Prime Minister made a statement at
the French British Summit where he
clearly stated that the United Kingdom
is going to respect international law
okay
um let's move on to Ukraine uh shall we
and the international criminal court has
issued an arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin is that news that you welcome it's
definitely a very important moment for
international law for the international
criminal justice because it means really
accountability at the highest level
and so yes we welcome it uh and on
Monday we are going to have here in
London a conference Dominic Rob has
invited Justice ministers from all over
Europe to discuss how we can strengthen
the work of the international criminal
court and I think it sends a very clear
signal also to everybody in Russia about
what can happen if they are part of
crimes against humanity do you think it
sends an important message to other
global leaders as well Vladimir Putin's
due to be meeting the Chinese president
for example do you think it will perhaps
send a bit of a signal to countries who
are perhaps not recognizing Putin's
crimes yes definitely and we have
123 countries who are part of the
international criminal court
and for all of them it will always be a
question can you still talk and receive
somebody like Putin and there is an
International arrest warrant so all of
that will limit Putin's possibilities
but Sophie let me also say that we have
to look also at the political Fallout of
that because what does it mean
will this mean that Russia's position on
the war will harden even more so there
are many many implications which need to
be taken into account and you think
there is a risk of that there is a risk
of that but at the same time I think
within the Putin Administration many
people will have now second thoughts
about their participation in this in
this crime of aggression in this war and
now let's talk a bit about weapons
because Poland and Slovakia have decided
to send fighter jets to Ukraine do you
think Germany would consider doing that
in the future
um we don't have the f-16s Ukraine has
requested but nevertheless I think it's
a very important move by Poland and
Slovakia to do that we are currently
putting together a big International
Alliance to send the leopard tanks so we
are building up more than two battalions
tank battalions training has just
finished and I would expect the leopard
to arrive as soon as possible in Ukraine
Germany for obvious historical reasons
has a reluctance to send armaments to
keep tracked into conflicts how much of
a journey would you say that your
country has been on in the last year
with a war in Ukraine yeah it was a
fundamental change of our policy not
only on arms delivery but also towards
Russia
but I mean the fact that we are now
leading this coalition to send a large
amount of Tanks to maintain them to
procure the artillery the ammunition the
logistics I think all of that shows that
Germany is now really in a leading
position on supporting Ukraine on the
military side we are more or less at the
same level as the United Kingdom but if
you take everything together we are I
would say the second support of Ukraine
internationally
do you think you're a bit slow Off the
Mark initially
was it more difficult discussion in
Germany that's something very clearly
and we had
to totally restructure our Russia policy
that's why it took a little bit longer
than in other countries and is that
because of the energy dependence on
Russia in particular no I think it had
more to do with the historic
relationship which would not forget that
the Soviet Union was part of achieving
German reunification that we all tried
to build up
a system in Europe where we could
include Russia in a in a in an
International Security architecture and
regrettably that has failed now we have
to learn our lessons from them it's
interesting to hear talk about that um
so openly uh now I want to talk a bit
about brexit because of course we have
these votes in House of Commons on
Wednesday on the Winds of framework
what is your message to conservative MPS
to dup MPS unions to MPS from Northern
Ireland who might be looking at this and
thinking I can't support this yeah I I
think it's a very good compromise
that has been worked out quietly over
four months between the European
commission and the British government
uh it's a compromise like always it
preserves The Good Friday agreement it
preserves East-West trade it means that
that the border between the Republic of
Ireland and Northern Ireland can stay
open so I think it achieves all the main
objectives and what I hear very often
from business people in Northern Ireland
is what they need is predictability and
stability and I think the Winds of
rainbow can achieve that I guess they're
from the unionist perspective in
Northern Ireland
their priority is being treated like the
rest of the UK so that they are treated
in exactly the same way as Glasgow as
Nottingham as London and for them that
doesn't achieve it do you think that
people in the EU really understand the
depth of feeling from the DP and others
yes I think we we do that and the
commission has reached out I myself have
met several times Jeffrey Donaldson
obviously we understand the
sensitivities of the dup and other
unionists but at the same time I think
we need a compromise which allows us to
have the necessary confidence in the
agreement and I think this has been
achieved so Sophie let me say that we
are very confident not only that there
will be an overwhelming majority
in the House of Commons but also that
this is an agreement where we can build
on to strengthen the relationship
between the United Kingdom and the
European Union how different has it been
for the EU and for Germany and others
dealing with Rishi sunak as opposed to
Boris Johnson and this trust
I think that with prime minister sunak
and especially the relationship he has
developed with the president of the
European commission Ms fonderlein is a
relationship of trust and this is
something we can build on so we have
full confidence that the British
government is really going to implement
what was agreed and as we know that was
not the case with Boris Johnson how
would you describe the relationship with
Boris Johnson
I would say that the relationship was
really at a at a very low point there
was no trust that things that are agreed
will be implemented and this is
absolutely different now so I think we
can look into a brighter future in the
relationship between the United Kingdom
and the European Union okay thank you
very much for coming on the program
thank you Sophie
well as usual the take we'll follow this
program just after 9 30 a chance to
analyze today's interviews talk through
any news lines out with adapters to Sam
Coates but we can get a quick take from
him now and what stood out to him this
morning uh Sam it feels like the big
story around today has been the Rwanda
deal and that visit by sweller Braverman
is that what's really stood out on the
program was there anything else you want
to pick out
so I think Richie sunak has probably had
the best three or so weeks of his time
as prime minister but it's talking about
the Rwanda policy all the other issues
that are cropped up on the program this
morning it's just clear how difficult
things still are for him whether it's
Rwanda I'm reminded that the biggest
opponent out there isn't Gary lineker
but Theresa May the former Home
Secretary and prime minister who's
opposing that deal on grounds if it gets
rid of her modern slavery uh changes and
she just doesn't think it deals with the
main issue which is overstayers an
extraordinary admission from Oliver dad
and on the program as well that funding
that NHS pay deal 1.5 billion pounds has
got to be found for that well that's got
to come potentially from the NHS budget
not the front line bits but that means
maybe scrapping head count it means
maybe scaling back on digital
transformation problems at The Institute
for fiscal studies said on Friday that
could mean effectively the NHS wobbles
along and then needs a out in a few
months time then there's brexit and
there's Boris Johnson the to-do list is
still very full after listening to this
morning's interviews yeah it certainly
is it's one of those interviews where
it's like right there was so much that I
could ask you about I'm gonna have to
whittle this down uh Sam thank you very
much indeed we'll have more from Sam at
around half past nine
now to the s p leadership race to
replace Nicholas sturgeon it's our third
and final interview of the three
candidates to take that job now Kate
Forbes doesn't do interviews on Sundays
for religious reasons usually it would
be no big deal to pre-record an
interview with a politician but when it
comes to the s p it turns out that two
days really is an awfully long time in
politics because since our interview the
head of communications quit after
unwittingly giving out false information
about s p membership numbers and now the
party's chief executive Peter Murrell
has also resigned after taking
responsibility for the fias gate now Mr
Murrell by the way also happens to be
Nicola sturgeon's husband so that's all
worth bearing in mind when you listen to
this interview with Kate Forbes we
started by talking about independence
I think that's the Democratic approach I
think too much in our political debate
right now is vitriolic it's abusive it's
disrespectful and actually when it comes
to the SMP if we want to win
independence it comes down to respecting
our fellow citizens and the reasons why
they haven't yet been persuaded I think
many in the SMP are surprised that there
hasn't been a more substantial shift of
support for Independence not least when
we've seen a conservative government
attack Devolution where in the throes of
a Tory cost of living crisis and so on
and I think for me as leader it's about
reaching out beyond the divides reaching
out to people who haven't yet been
persuaded and making the case for how
Scotland can be wealthier and fairer you
know in the in the context of a
leadership contest it's easy to forget
that there's a lot more than that unites
us than divides us not least wanting to
eradicate poverty wanting to see a
growing prosperous economy wanting to
ensure that people aren't fuel poor I
think the path to that is good
governance and ultimately putting the
powers around Scotland's future into the
hands of those in Scotland
I talk about good governance
um you wrote a joint letter with Ash
Regan calling for information about the
current membership status of the SMP
what exactly are your concerns about
this process
well I have no concerns about the
process so I have full confidence in in
the Integrity of the election contest
all three candidates in fact were asking
for SMP membership figures because it
stands to reason that in any election
the candidates should know the size of
the electorate the size of the uh the
group of people that they're trying to
persuade and I'm very relieved that
those figures have now been confirmed
but I think those figures demonstrate
that continuity won't cut it my whole
pitch has been around building on the
smp's track record but re-earning the
trust of our SMP voters as well as the
wider public and the fact that we'd lost
so many members in such a short period
of time I think demonstrates that we do
need to shift focus and deliver change
continuity won't cut it who is the
continuity candidate
well I think if you were to ask the
other candidates and at least one has a
quite happily and readily accepted that
he is the the continuity candidate and I
have great respect for his approach But
ultimately there is a profound Choice
facing SMP members because I offer a new
approach I want to put our economy front
and center I want to reach out to no
voters as I've already said and I want
to ensure that we eradicate poverty and
rebuild the strength of the trust that
we enjoy with the Scottish people that's
how the SNP has won multiple elections
over the last 16 years and if we want to
continue to win elections then I believe
that we are at a Crossroads and we need
to take the approach that will
ultimately ensure we maintain that trust
going forward so you say that you've got
confidence in the process Ash Regan told
me last week who's obviously another of
the candidates that she thinks that
there's a conflict of interest with
Nicholas sturgeon's husband remaining as
SNP chief executive while the contest is
ongoing do you agree with that
no I don't because I think that we have
obviously the the third party electronic
provider of voting and and also because
I have full confidence in the process
I'll ultimately this will be determined
by SMP members and I think there would
be outrage from the SNP members if there
was any perception of a lack of
Integrity so I think steps have been
taken in order to ensure the Integrity
of the process and I'm certainly
confident that whoever is elected will
be the person who SMP members have
chosen
now after her resignation Nicholas
sturgeon said Scotland is a progressive
country and the views of the next first
Minister therefore matter do you
consider yourself to have Progressive
views
I do indeed I think we live in a
pluralistic tolerant society which
allows space for everyone and of course
the definition of progressivity is that
we stand up for those who have no voice
and ensure that we are representing
their interest in Scotland today there
are extraordinarily deep social economic
inequalities with one in four children
in poverty with the life expectancy
between those in the most deprived and
the least deprived areas far too wide
and I focused during my campaign in not
just meeting with those who perhaps have
a vote but meeting for example with
women from ethnic minority groups who
have gone through the Asylum Seeker
process and who truly have no voice and
Ukrainian refugees so I think Scotland
has made great strides we need to be a
welcoming tolerant country and my hope
is that there's place for everyone the
Scottish government committed by the end
of the year to have ended gay and trans
conversion therapy now in the later on
Monday night on Sky News our political
editor Beth Rigby asked you six times if
you would ban conversion therapy even if
the individual consented and you didn't
exactly give a straight answer to that
now you've had a bit of time to think
what is the position on that
yeah so I said in that debate and I'll
see again today that conversion therapy
is abhorrent uh we've been through a
process where many people have shared
their lived experiences and on a hugely
sensitive issue like this I think it's
important that it's those lived
experiences that inform the approach
that we take to the debate now I
understand that there are people who
will say that there is no non-coercive
approach to conversion therapy and I
certainly you know I'm not here to to to
argue with that I'm here to build on the
experiences that people have shared and
ensure that any approach we take to the
legislation it reflects those lived
experiences but it is a very very
sensitive issue and I do think it's
important that rather than give you sort
of quick sort of gotcha answers
um on a matter of such importance that
we do reflect on the consultation
responses and we ensure the leg
legislation it bans such an abhorrent
practice
and now just finally there are three
people in the race but really it's kind
of two horses at the front yourself and
hanza Yusuf
do you think he'll make a good first
minister
I think he would yes I do think I think
he has great talents I think he's got an
ability to connect with anybody to to to
reach people he has obviously been one
of my colleagues for many years and I've
seen him in action and I think that
right now the people of the SMP have a
genuine choice to make and what I offer
is change building on our track record
bringing a level of competence and a
track record to my Approach and ensuring
that we do deliver economic Prosperity
as a means of eradicating poverty
would you serve in his cabinet if you
asked
well it's it's somewhat presumptuous to
assume I will be asked and but certainly
and I'd be happy to serve with him or to
serve under him
thank you very much indeed Kate Forbes
thank you
uh Kate Forbes uh they're talking to me
a little bit earlier this week we're
gonna have more on the SNP Fiasco
implosion difficulties whatever you uh
describe like to describe it when we
have a bit of a panel chat later on the
program with samashar and Aisha hazarika
to former government advisors so that
should be interesting to see their take
now the stripes that have plagued the
public sector for months from the Health
Service to schools trains and more seem
to have an end in sight it was started
by nursing unions accepting a new offer
this week to put to their members now
teachers and others are in intensive
talks but there are lots of disputes
remaining including thousands of civil
servants and many votes and members of
the PCS Union we can now speak to its
Channel secretary mark sawatka thank you
for being on the program can you just
outline exactly what your members are
asking for uh good morning Sophie yes I
represent uh Civil Service workers
um from the most Junior grades up to
more senior levels across 250 different
government departments
and we've had the lowest pay increase
anywhere in the public sector the
government's given its own Workforce two
percent we have 40 000 civil servants
using food banks incredibly forty five
thousand civil servants claim inward
benefits the benefits they themselves
administer and it's now been revealed in
just two government departments hmrc and
DWP 49
000 staff Sophie are on the national
minimum wage people who chase tax
Dodgers pay benefits make decisions on
Asylum claims so we've asked for a 10
pay raise because inflation has averaged
at 10 food inflation actually was 16
last week for the staple Goods our
members are struggling to buy and I have
to say I find it extraordinary that the
minister for the cabinet office that you
interviewed earlier on did not even
mention that 135 000 of his staff were
on strike earlier this week a hundred
and ten thousand of this staff are on
strike in the first of February and he's
going to have 1500 of his staff in every
pass office in the UK out for a
five-week strike starting in two weeks
time I think it goes to confirm the
utter contempt they hold their own
Workforce in and that's why we're on
strike
a five-week strike by members of the
passport office five weeks I mean that
doesn't sound like a strike it sounds
like a sabbatical
it sounds like people giving everything
they can to strain every single to force
their employer to recognize that when
they go into food banks and claiming
benefits because they work for the
government it is obscene and we've tried
for months to get the government to
engage it's great news they're talking
to the health unions and the education
unions but why won't they talk to their
own Workforce Richie sunac applauded his
Workforce during the pandemic he lauded
us for delivering the furlough scheme
for delivering three million claims to
Universal Credit many people died in the
Civil Service who went into work to keep
our borders safe and provide Frontline
Services yet a two percent pay rise is
lower than anywhere in the economy and
they will not even negotiate with us and
I think most of your viewers would find
that utterly astonishing and that's why
people are having to take escalating
strike action because they have no
choice if they want to get themselves
out of in work poverty
um you say that you want to see a 10 pay
rise for your members and the nurses of
course accepted a one-off payment for
this year and a pay rise of five percent
from next year is that the kind of offer
that you would consider
well the Health Service of course in
effect have had a six percent pay raise
for 2022 on a five percent pay raise for
2023 firefighters had a seven percent
pay raise last year five percent this
year teachers room talks we're saying to
the government if you call us in with
money on the table we are prepared to
negotiate with you but those
negotiations must ensure that their
Workforce are not poorer at the end of
the year than they were at the start of
the year and that's currently what we
face and that's why I repeat the point
why can't even the minister responsible
on your show find it within himself to
acknowledge that he's had unprecedented
strikes amongst government workers and
yet he's not even prepared to talk to
them and I personally think that's it
that's a scandal and that's why passport
workers are going on strike for five
weeks but not just passport workers
there'll be workers in the British
library in the department of work and
pensions in the tax offices in the
borders across every government
Department unless they do the thing that
they know they have to but so far seem
reluctant too which is get into
negotiations with money on the table
now while I have you as you obviously
represent many workers in the Civil
Service I just want to talk to you about
Dominic Robb who of course is facing
allegations of alleged bullying he
denies it is currently being looked into
now on the program a few weeks ago he
said he would resign if a bullying
complaint against him was upheld but he
did also say that it wouldn't be right
for him to be suspended or to step aside
while complaints are being investigated
because in his words it meant civil
servants or others could knock out a
cabinet minister for political or
malicious reasons do you think that's a
fair point
no I don't and what's malicious is
bullying in the workplace and whilst
Dominic Robb is going through a process
we know that pretty Patel was found to
have bullied civil servants in the home
office he actually got away with hardly
a sanction we know that so well a
Braverman broken ministerial code yet
now she issues emails accusing her own
Workforce of blocking her Rwanda policy
and we have Dominic Robb with not but
one complaint but numerous complaints
and the point I would make is if one of
my members Sophie had an allegation like
this against them they would be
suspended in fact we have had members
who have been dismissed for just doing a
tweet or a social media post that
doesn't cause offense to anyone let
alone allegations of bullying in the
workplace so he should step aside or he
should be suspended while the
allegations are investigated and it's
time I think that the government
realized the way they are being seen to
treat their own Workforce causes a
collapse of morale and causes people to
really quite question whether they can
play a role in public service when
they're not only treated like this by
ministers but are then scapegoated by
ministers as soon as something goes
wrong
um important of courses I don't denies
the allegations the report is ongoing it
will be the Prime Minister who
ultimately decides is that acceptable as
well
no I don't think it is because I think
we've already seen two examples with
very high profile ministers whether
that's pretty Patel or braver men found
to have breach the ministerial code and
yet nothing seemed to have been done
about it and therefore that brings into
question whether indeed the Prime
Minister himself doesn't act acting
partially because it seems the prime
ministers can turn a blind day for their
political colleagues I don't think
anybody could have trust in our process
because ultimately even when you're
found to have done something wrong it
seems that you can still survive without
any sanction
okay thank you very much really
interesting to talk uh this morning
marks Walker speaking to us there from
West Wales thank you
well it's been an absolutely packed show
so we're gonna try out something a
little bit different on the program
today that I'm really looking forward to
um because of all the stuff on the
program and also a busy week coming up
we decided we are going to you know kick
our heels off we're going to have a bit
of a more relaxed conversation with two
ladies that I'm going to introduce you
to now because they certainly know their
way around Westminster former political
advisor to the labor leader Ed miliband
Aisha hazarika and samashar who is a
special advisor to the conservative Home
Secretary Sanchez thank you both for
being with us good morning good morning
um if I know we've been talking an awful
lot about the immigration policy the
Rwanda deal so I just want to kind of
start off with that if I may Salma it
feels like this is a fight that the
government is leaning into would that be
fair yeah I think so I think there are a
couple of things first of all the prime
minister made it very clear in January
that this was one of the top priorities
and this is what he needed to tackle and
so there's going to have to be some
delivery on this but more uh
fundamentally I think it sits in the
Public's Consciousness about this idea
that there is something that the country
doesn't have control over
um and I think that it's uh it's it's
that that is essentially driving the
fact that they need to make a big
decision and a big push on the Rwanda
policy in order to kind of in some ways
I hate to term it in this way but have a
victory on that victories can be harder
of course uh because it as you say it
depends on the deal well I mean there's
so much to go through it's there's the
an appeal in the courts at the moment
and then also they're going to have to
pass the legislation which is not going
to be an easy thing to do and we have to
stop the small boats the podium the the
slogan I mean it says pretty clearly
what they want to do
is it a difficult one for labor or do
you think that actually this is again
something that they're quite Keen to
have a dividing line on well I think
it's been interesting for Libra because
immigration is often been quite a tricky
issue for for Libra in the past but I
think because the numbers have gone up
so much under a conservative
Administration I think what the labor
party is really sort of focusing on is
the fact that the conservatives will
talk tough on immigration they've made
it a priority for themselves and yet the
numbers go up and up and up so they're
sort of their kind of focus is there's a
big gap between the sort of politics and
the the rhetoric and the actual reality
of the delivery but I think what that
signals is that the conservatives have
made a calculation that this is all
about the Optics this is about having
the row about immigration but it's quite
a dangerous game to play because if we
got the local elections coming up very
very soon and as we run into the general
election which is probably at least a
minimum a year away if those figures
don't start coming down and there's no
evidence they will then the
conservatives could have ramped up this
expectation and they will have failed to
deliver on it the only thing that I
would say to that is that labor is going
to have to have a position on this and I
think as as we get closer to the
election they are going to have to say
would they match the conservative plans
or would they do something different but
I think they have set up some policies I
mean I think actually I mean indeed the
labor parties had some criticism from
the left for being kind of a bit too
sort of Hardline on immigration they
have said look we have to get the the
boots down this is we have to have a
sort of Center in France we have to have
much more money going into this but I
think the the big difference I think
between the labor stance and the
conservative stances unless you open up
more safe and legal routes people are
still going to get in those boots and I
think and also having no returns policy
with France as well means it's quite
hard to see how you actually stop these
small boots so I would say that you know
laborers actually I think being quite
tough on immigration there's plenty in
within the party on the left who
actually think you know we're not happy
with the labor party and being tough on
immigration I think the labor party
wants to be
um quite common sense on immigration but
have that level of compassion
particularly with these safe and legal
groups it was actually quite interesting
talking to the German ambassador because
obviously um one of the ways for both
labor and the conservatives is to set up
these returns policies and I think labor
in exactly the same position as
conservatives on it and he was like look
transporting with the eea that's not
going to happen I thought it was quite
clear actually yeah which is another I'm
afraid another bad result of where
things are since we've left the EU
um I want to talk a bit about the s p as
well I'll be honest I'm going to level
with you it was slightly frustrating to
have done the interview with cape Forbes
before this huge implosion with the
resignation of the chief executive of
the Scottish national party but that is
where we are
um what is actually going on with the s
p what I mean well I'm going to look
through Asia here
I mean I had a big discussion yesterday
on my show about this and and Chris
Duren who writes the new States and I
think had a great way of of freezing he
said that the resignation of Nicola
sturgeon is like a pin being pulled out
of grenade and that's sort of how it
feels for the the SMP it does feel like
the party is going into this big
inclusion and the shock resignation of
Peter Morrell who's the chief executive
officer of the party and also the
husband of Nicholas sturgeon over sort
of misinformation being given out about
about these figures and why that's
important as you've been sort of
exploring is that some of the candidates
particularly Ash Regan feel that they
can't trust the process because they
feel that the party machine is rigged
for Hamza Yusuf in terms of being the
continuity candidate but I think the
bigger picture on all of this is that
you do you have seen the SMP which has
arguably been one of the most successful
political projects in the United Kingdom
over the last two decades apart from
getting Independence itself yeah but in
terms of you know they've done dominated
Scottish politics they've sort of wiped
out the labor party and large parts of
the conservative party the liberal
Democrats they've been very dominant in
Scottish politics for sort of lit for
sort of 15 years now with Nicola
sturgeon going it has been a bit of like
watching a house of cards collapse the
big question is is this going to benefit
labor come the next general election and
the big elephant in the room is there's
still no plan for Independence because
whoever wins the next general election
whether it's Rishi sunac whether it's
case timer they've said no we don't want
to let you have Independence um as both
of you are former advisors I just
wondered if I if you had like a Pang of
Sympathy for the guy called Murray foot
who was the head of communications for
the SNP he went out there basically
saying facts about the s p membership
numbers that turn out to be incorrect
and he resigned effectively saying that
his people within the s p had given him
wrong information Did You Have A Bit of
Sympathy because you know he went out
there putting his
uh reputation on the line if you like
I do have some sympathy in the sense
that if you can't control the things
that he's you know been given to say
then he shouldn't be the person who's on
the chopping block but this is this is
the distinction between people who are
actually decision makers and people who
are essentially advisors and I think
that perhaps that line was crossed with
him having to resign over it because you
know ultimately you're there to kind of
deliver something you're not there to
sort of make the decision and you've got
to have trust in the people telling you
what's going on exactly you have to have
that level also I think what's
interesting is that I think if if Murray
had not resigned a wonder if Peter
Morrell would have clung on and put that
statement out yeah really saying very
clearly I'm resigning but something's
going on here I think that was a big big
Catalyst for for this and you know
whatever Winger politics you're in
certainly when I started as a junior
press officer in the Ministry of
Agriculture fisheries and food literally
like centuries ago I remember on my
first day it was like the oldies like
Jurassic Park it was like but I do
remember my chief press officer saying
to me and this is probably advice we've
all had we said you know if you don't
know the answer to something say you
don't know the answer what you should
not do is lie yeah yeah because it
trashes your reputation whether you're a
press officer whether you're an advisor
of course and whether you're a minister
yeah you always remember from the
journalist's perspective yes absolutely
if everyone has told you an actual
untruth you're like don't trust that
person yeah well that's it the line's
been crossed
um are you should touch a little bit
about the Electoral implications of the
SMP and the succession for Nicholas
sturgeon How concerned do you think the
conservatives are about it because look
you mentioned the local elections and
the general election next year it's
already a really thin Landing zone for
Richie sunac and if labor start picking
up seats in Scotland that's going to be
even harder I think it's always been a
difficult uh question for the
conservatives that if labor have a
Resurgence in Scotland what does that
mean for us nationally and you know I
don't think anybody's under laboring
under any pretense that this is going to
be a really tough gig for Rishi soon act
to try and sort of clamber back to an
election Victory but the s p is facing
the consequences of having had a strong
leader for such a long time because
essentially if there's one plant that
grows really strong it sort of deprives
the rest of sunlight so we're going to
have to see actually how much any of the
candidates whichever candidate comes
through is able to sort of galvanize the
s p against labor and again whether the
unionist cause is strengthened and
whether the conservatives can pick up
from that I don't think it's likely that
conservatives believe that there's going
to be a big rush to them over there but
again it's also not likely that there's
going to be a huge rush to labor I think
kirst armor has to do some work there as
well I'm sure about that I I think
are quite recently I'd say a couple of
weeks labor thinking they'd be lucky if
they may be picked up about sort of 10
seats in Scotland but I think with all
the turmoil of Nicola sturgeon going and
the fact that she was such a sort of
elite political athlete compared to sort
of what's on offer now she was like such
a fluent strong persuasive Communicator
I don't think you know whoever follows
her is going to be in that mold I think
labor are now feeling much more
confident about picking up more seats I
still think the SMP will be the dominant
Force but remember if there comes a
point where labor can let's say pick up
an additional let's say 15 20 so that's
quite a Tipping Point which is very
helpful for the calculus across the
whole country in terms of taking care of
starmer into dining Street and then if
kyosama does become Prime Minister then
he has a chance to show Scotland look
this is how I could get better for you
with a labor Administration and then you
could see some inroads being made for
the unionist cause underly so you think
there could be like a labor SMP tie-in
no if the numbers don't go no no I think
that basically I think the fact that the
SNP doing worse means that kusama will
get a majority really interesting um I'd
love to have you both on again it's been
really fascinating to hear your talk
before you go
Oliver Dowden said that Rishi sunak
respects Boris Johnson I think that's
fine
I think uh yeah I do actually because I
I think that you know he delivered
breakfast unit was a brexit here I think
there was definitely you know this fight
Boris Johnson is this big character I
don't I don't think that there's um any
way that that wasn't true but it's
interesting he's giving everybody a free
vote
that that tells us a lot I respect him
and not want to not want to facilitate
his demise yourself
that is gonna it's gonna be fiery next
week it really uh is thank you both very
much for being out on the program uh
this morning that is it for this week's
safety Ridge on Sunday but in a moment
after the break we can be running
through today's interviews and seeing
what we learned with our Deputy
political editor Sam coats thanks for
joining us this Monday
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Sunday the take a chance to look back at
our interviews this morning on the
program try and work out what we learned
what it means for the week ahead it was
one of these mornings where you know I
had the list of potential topics to talk
to Oliver dad and about uh was it going
to be strikes was it going to be
immigration was going to be brexit was
it going to be Boris Johnson and I had
to really try and Whittle it down the
budget another thing I almost forgot
there but it did feel this morning I was
Keen to really try and talk to him about
what he makes of the Rwanda policy one
of the key dividing lines in politics
one of those things where you're seeing
very different positions from the
government and the labor party on and
also to talk a bit about the language
because obviously that's something that
has really come under as scrutiny as
well in recent weeks the Home Secretary
claimed that billions of people could
potentially Hope to come to the United
Kingdom let's have a little listen to
how he responded and then we can talk to
some coats off the back
well it is a a function of the global
economy and differences in levels of
development that countries like the
United Kingdom France Germany United
States and others have potentially vast
numbers of people who wish to come here
as economic migrants secondly if you'll
let me finish this point secondly it is
the case that if you look at the numbers
we we were at a situation where there
were dozens of boats three or four years
ago we're at forty thousand uh last year
projected to rise further we have to be
willing to put a stop to this and there
are very very large numbers of people
who could potentially wish to enter the
United Kingdom and indeed other
developed countries uh for for economic
migration reasons
one of our pleased to say that as usual
we're joined by adaptive political
editor uh Sam Coates great to have you
on the program as usual this morning as
Sam
what do you make at the Rwanda policy
and do you think that the government
feels that actually look this is
something that's going to appeal to
voters that it's in a winning position
that's why they're leaning in or
actually do you think there are some
issues that are going to cause some
problems
well so for the reason we're talking
about the Rwanda policy is because
Zoella bravaman has been there she took
GB news and the telegraph uh to go and
see where migrants uh Asylum Seekers uh
who failed in their claims would go back
to to the government wants to talk about
this Rishi sunak wants to talk about it
we've been talking about it for a couple
of weeks because of the Gary lineker
Affair and before that was the weekend
before the whole policy was launched so
there is some confidence I think in
government that this is a politically
sensible terrain for them to go on
but just in the last half an hour I've
been just running through some of the
numbers because while Rishi Cena was off
in San Diego on Monday you had the first
vote on this and an extraordinary High
number of Tory MPS just declined to back
the government's own Rwanda policy and
the associated Asylum legislation 45 MPS
abstained or weren't there or didn't
turn up from that vote which is awfully
highly number for a government that has
a majority of just 66 once you take into
account all of the MPS that aren't there
in other words the government is very
confident about the politics of this
looking tough on an issue that people
care about but I think the big question
here is whether or not this ends up
happening and if this all comes crashing
down in legislative flames whether or
not the government ends up just looking
a little bit uncompetent incompetent
having not managed its own side properly
I mentioned before Theresa May is one of
the chief Chris politics of Richie sunax
policy she just doesn't think it's going
to deal with that many people most of
the people who are here as uh in the
country unnecessarily are overstayers on
their visa so she thinks that it's the
wrong target she thinks that uh it would
undermine some of the modern slavery
commitments that she as prime minister
did she's joined in the criticism of
this by Caroline notes she's the
chairman of the women and equality
select committee so there is a band of
MPS who in a couple of weeks time
probably about 10 days when this
legislation comes back I'm probably
going to go up a gear in their criticism
and we might then find that we move from
a situation where the government were on
comfortable sort of TV talking points
and that moves away to actually quite
tricky quite sticky implementation
because even if this gets through the
commons and the Lords even then it's
unclear where uh various uh attempted
refugees are held at one of the Asylum
centers there's just a plethora of
practice problems that means from where
I say it it's far from clear that this
is going to be still looking like a
success in nine months time that's
really interesting that does seem as you
say sam a very high number of
conservative MPS and not backing the
policy it might have different reasons
for it of course some of the individuals
but that does seem a bit of an outlier
doesn't it in terms of what you would
expect Sam they're talking a bit about
the implementation as well about how
easy it will be to fulfill that pledge
to stop the boats and I just want to
bring you in at the labor interview and
then talk to them off the back of that
because we also spoke to the shadow
leveling up secretary Lisa nandy and
touched on suela Bravo's use of language
that's a listen
what people say Gary lineker said is
very different from what Gary lineker
actually said the government has been
Keen to say that he was likening this to
the Nazis that he wasn't and I would
have utterly condemned that had he done
so I don't think he would have done so
frankly what he was pointing to was a
chilling comparison with an environment
in which people aren't free to be able
to challenge this sort of language and
behavior don't forget it was Sue Ella
bravaman who used really inhumane
language about the migrant crisis which
was roundly condemned not just by people
outside of politics but by people across
the political Spectrum including some of
her own colleagues
right let's bring Sam back in at shall
we we're really in culture War territory
again here aren't we
uh
absolutely and it's interesting uh the
labor party have decided to effectively
in and you heard that from uh the way
Lisa and Andy was talking and other
front bench has been talking to side uh
with Gary lineker uh the BBC presenter
briefly suspended uh for his social
media remarks about the government's
Rwanda policy
um because they think that that's a
winning position and there is some
polling to suggest the public oppose the
suspension of Gary lineker albeit
briefly from the BBC match the day
program but but what this also does I
think and this is the game of uh of Tory
strategists is it highlights uh what
they think is a labor weakness on the
issue of migration and listening
particularly to kirst armor and a bit
there to Lisa and Andy what they also
like to talk in uh in Broad terms about
the implementation issues rather than
the issues of principle when when you
hear Richie sunak versus kirstama in the
Commons which is sunak always emphasizes
the points of principle and policy and
kissed armor always emphasizes the the
fact that he he thinks there are many
many practical problems and the
government had tried this before and it
never really works and it's not going to
do anything uh and and and sort of shies
away from putting himself in a position
that doesn't also look tough because I
think there is a dilemma uh for labor
the party previously a free movement
that's now junked that to try and
reinforce that impression in people's
minds against a conservative party that
are trying to claim that labor never
changes its mind uh uh on and will
always be the party of free migration
which you know label would say is
absolutely not true but they've got to
hammer that through uh hammer that point
three to the government and it is just
politically tricky that's why we're
having this discussion because not only
would Rishi not say it's right but they
also spy it might just give them some
electoral advantage and there's just the
tiniest sign in uh in some polling work
done uh that questions around what
exactly Labor's immigration policy is is
starting to raise up uh the list of
questions people have for kirst armor
and Sam I know that something you and I
are always really Keen to face on is
strikes because we're aware of course as
many people are that how much of our
viewers and everyone's lives these are
really impacting strikes right across
the public sector so I just want to play
you what Oliver Dowden said when I spoke
to him about the NHS strikes that in
particular and how the pay rise that has
been agreed and has been put to members
how that's going to be funded
first of all it doesn't necessarily have
to come uh within the uh the envelope
for the the NHS of the 160 billion
pounds is the wider Department of Health
budget and there's The Wider budget
across all of government even within the
160 billion for the NHS not all of that
is going to be for Frontline uh services
so the Frontline Services we think about
are of course your hospitals your
doctor's surgeries and so on within a
budget that large the it is there is
potential to get efficiencies
and of course many of the public sector
workers are going on uh strike include
the Civil Service the PCS Union let's
listen to the other side of the argument
shall we it's Mark sawatka it's General
Secretary
I have to say I find it extraordinary
that the minister for the cabinet office
that you interviewed earlier on did not
even mention that 135 000 of his staff
were on strike earlier this week 110 000
of his staff are on strike on the first
of February and he's going to have 1500
of his staff in every passport office in
the UK out for a five-week strike
starting in two weeks time I think it
goes to confirm the utter contempt they
hold their own Workforce in and that's
why we're on strike
right let's bring in at Sam again I
think it's really important actually to
focus on the fact that this is not
additional money that the government is
going to give this is money that is
going to be have to be found presumably
from the NHS budget even if it's not the
Frontline of the NHL such NHS budget if
I can actually get my words out
um from that budget all the same
that's right Stephanie can I confess to
being pretty flabbergasted
um the conservative argument around
public sector pay has always been we've
got to manage the economy properly we
don't want to push up inflation we want
to know how we're going to pay for pay
Rises and what Oliver Dowden did was
come on your show and say there's great
news we've done a deal with the nurses
to give them effectively five percent
and we don't know how we're going to pay
for it it might come from the NHS budget
the non-frontline but it might come from
other bits of the health budget that
doesn't include the NHS or it might come
from from from from somewhere else they
just don't know and that feels odd and
if I'm being honest Sophie it doesn't
feel true I I don't I don't believe they
don't know where the money's coming from
so I I think that's a lie so let's uh uh
so I find that a complicated answer that
I'm uncomfortable with because of course
they have an idea where this money is
coming from and they're just not being
honest about it but it but but he did
say Oliver dad and did say it might come
from the non-frontline bits of the NHS
budget now back in 2021 when they did
the kind of as it were the spending
settlement the spending review
settlement for the NHS
at that point they asked the NHS
specifically for 12 billion pounds of
efficiencies right so the NHS is already
finding money from its own budget and
then last Autumn they had to give them
NHS more money because it couldn't keep
up with inflation and now potentially as
a result of the nurses deal they're
going to whack maybe the NHS budget the
non-front light bit with you know
another 1.5 billion pounds to to find to
pay the pay deals which is going to have
to go on reducing head kind or maybe
stopping some of those sort of digital
uh future proofing for the NHS I mean
it's all just very very bizarre but I
just think the the idea that it is a
possibility according to ministers that
the NHS gets less money uh for for some
kinds of uh services not Frontline ones
but some of the things some of its
operations so that it could fund this
pay rise that it was so resistant to for
quite a long time it I mean just hurts
your head yeah it does and also like you
say like okay there's Frontline at NHS
services but that doesn't mean that the
other parts of the NHS don't directly
support those Frontline Services it
feels to me like it's not an easy
distinction that you can just draw or
this is the important part of the NHS
budget and actually none of this affects
patient care when of course it feels
much more complicated than that
um Sam well I've got you I really want
to talk to you about next week because
Boris Johnson of course is going to be
up in front of the Privileges uh
committee it's going to be a big moment
uh whether or not they're going to rule
of course on whether or not he misled
Parliament over partygate and I think it
was pretty clear from Oliver dad and
this morning that MPS are going to get a
free vote on that what do you think
that's going to mean
oh it's going to be a blockbuster a week
or two in the House of Commons I'm very
sad uh to be out of the game for the
next two weeks and about to miss it but
Wednesday I think is going to be the
most uh explosive day in British
products because there are two things
going on there is uh Rishi sunak pushing
through the brexit deal that Boris
Johnson opposes the Windsor framework
and then at the same time there's going
to be uh four to six hours of testimony
from Boris Johnson about whether or not
he lied in partygate uh that will
essentially inform a select committee
that's going to decide whether it thinks
that Boris Johnson lied to Parliament
and if they think that he did then
there's going to be a vote a free vote
in the House of Commons that could
determine whether or not Boris Johnson
is suspended could face a by-election
and could be slung out of politics all
together so how Boris Johnson handles
himself on Wednesday it's going to be
fascinating I think that the key point
to remember is that Boris Johnson is
effectively trying to prove that he was
told that uh everything he said that to
the commons uh was was true that he was
breaking the law by what was going on
inside Downing Street now we've seen
from evidence and testimony already
released by that committee that they are
minded to condemning the evidence put
forward by the Privileges committee uh
paints a pretty damning picture of Boris
Johnson they say he was attended parties
he could see parties from his own front
door within Downing Street they say that
he knew what was going on he was
intimately involved with some of the um
uh with with some of the conversations
they also question they also clearly the
Privileges committee have had private
conversations with aides that have been
pretty damning it's still got the
capacity to get very very ugly it's
going to be an extraordinary day